- I want to be bigger than Adele.
- That should be your goal.
- Yeah the word "Adele" is
just something that no one
should (beep) with basically.
What's the worse that can happen?
The worse that can happen is you fail.
I've only written songs from the heart.
I want to keep having
stuff to do everyday.
♫ Cause darling your soul
♫ could never grow old it's evergreen.
(screams)
- What's up Belief Nation it's Evan.
My one word is Believe and
I believe that you have the
ability to do something special
that can change the planet.
So to help you on your journey today,
we're going to learn from
singer/songwriter Ed Sheeran
and my take on his top ten
rules to success, volume two.
Rule number one is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
(upbeat music)
♫ I'm in love with your body
- Now I read that your goal
is to sell 20 million copies
of this album Divide, and
you want to overtake Adele
in terms of record sales.
- Yeah and I feel like me
saying this, a lot of people
will like, that's such
an arrogant thing to say.
But I think you need to
choose someone that's at the
top of their game.
Like I probably won't sell
20 million records and I
probably won't ever be as big as Adele,
but if you don't aim for
the top of the mountain
how are you ever going to get halfway?
- Right, and set high goals for yourself.
- Yeah. But the problem
is that my point never
comes across with that
because that quote is now
just, I want to be bigger than Adele.
- That should be your goal.
- Yeah, the word Adele is just
something that no one should
(bleep) with basically.
(laughs)
So if you put that into
any sentence prepare to be
shut down.
I don't play with a band,
I use a sound pedal which
is all live and built up
so Wembley was always like
even an arena I thought
I couldn't do an arena so
but then when I did an arena
and it was fine I was like,
"Well we might as well try Wembley,
"what's the worst that could happen?"
The worst that could happen is you fail.
But you still sold Wembley
so the worst that could
happen is that you fail and
you move back to the arenas
which is not, that's what
everyone else does so that's
quite a cool thing.
- [Charlie] How many people were there?
- It was at 87,000 every night.
- [Interviewer] 87,000.
- Yeah.
It's a big ol' stadium, but
the thing is like if you
fail you've not lost
anything, and if you achieve
and make it good the
possibilities are endless.
- How imposing is social
media on your life?
Did you just get sick of it?
You just wanted to detox?
- No I enjoy diving into
it and kind of being on it
but it's just quite toxic
to be, you just end up
getting really self
conscious about yourself.
I wasn't a hugely self conscious
guy before and then you
just read into everything
and you kind of end up
searching for people
slagging you off and like
looking for people saying mean things.
Yeah.
And since I've been off
it it's been glorious.
I want a 30 year career
not a five year career.
I don't want to do it, you know
we could have done stadiums
a lot earlier on, we could
have done arenas a lot
earlier on, we could have
released five albums in five
years but it's a marathon
and not a sprint.
And I remember being around
a lot of my contemporaries
that were doing so much
better than me and my manager
being like, "Just slow
down, slow down, slow down."
And now I'm still here six
years on and they're not and
I think the whole music
industry you need to just
pace yourself.
Just take time to make great
albums, you don't have to
stick out music all the
time to stay relevant.
You'll stay relevant by making
great records and to make
great records you have to
spend a lot of time to do them.
I've only written songs from the heart.
I don't really see the point
of making music if it's not
an expression of self
or a form of therapy.
If I have a bad day I want
to write a song, I don't
want to write a song to have
a hit, I want to write a song
cause I wanted it to make me feel better.
It's never been about the
audience or pleasing people
or trying to fit in, it's
just been about myself and
my love for music and I
guess that has come across.
I think that this album is
very much, it's rooted in
my comfort zone but there are
certain times where I step
out of the comfort zone.
And the reason I chose Sing
as the sort of lead single
for it, that being a step
out of the comfort zone
is I had an acoustic ballad
song I wanted to put out
first and whenever I played
it to people they were like,
"Oh, it's nice, yeah, really
cool, really nice song."
When you played Sing to people
it really polarized everyone.
They either hated it or
they loved it but they spoke
about it a lot, you know you'd
speak to people and they'd
be like, "Oh, yeah I heard
about that song cause so and so
"is talking about it."
But no one was talking
about the acoustic tune.
So I thought by sticking out
a song that sort of makes
people talk it would be a
lot better for the album.
I do work hard and I do try
and keep going but it could
be a lot worse.
This is the best job that
I could possibly have and I
could be working in a
supermarket or something.
The days off that don't
exist because I don't
want them to exist.
I want to keep having
stuff to do every day.
It excites me to travel
around the world and play for
people that genuinely love my
music and smile and they're
all happy and people are nice
to me when we do interviews
and stuff, it's good.
I've made this album on
tour and I'm making the next
album on tour and it's
about finding the time, like
I've got a producer to
bring a mobile studio into
every dressing room that I go
into, and every hotel room,
and on the tour bus, so.
In between doing meet and
greets and the gig, you'll
try and write a song and
then after the gig you'll
then on the bus journey
to the next place you'll
try to write a song, so
it's about finding the
time to make it happen.
For me success is always
stepping out on stage and feeling
people genuinely happy to hear your songs.
Yeah, that's always been,
when I know a song's a hit
is when you play it
and you just see people
light up in the crowd and smile.
I think that's how you know
rather than seeing stats and
figures.
- Right.
- Stats and figures are
great as well to look at.
Everyone needs their ego
massaged sometimes but I think
the gigs, gigs are the ones.
- [Cameraman] What's happening Ed?
- Just going to go sing a song.
Should I just roll up?
- [Cameraman] Just roll up, roll up.
♫ I know you will still love me the same
♫ Cause darling your
soul could never grow old
♫ It's evergreen
♫ And baby your
♫ Smile's forever in my mind and memory
♫ I'm thinking about how
♫ People fall in love in mysterious ways
♫ Maybe it's all part of the plan
♫ I'll just fall in love
with you every single
♫ Day, I just want to tell you I am
♫ So honey, now
♫ Take me into your loving arms
♫ Kiss me under the
light of a thousand stars
♫ Place your head on my beating heart
♫ I'm thinking out loud
♫ But maybe we found
love right where we are
(applause)
♫ La, la, la, la, la, la,
la, la, la, la, la, la, la
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Husam Ezzi asked me to.
If there's someone you'd
like to vote on for the
next top 10 check out the
link in the description
and go and have your say.
Finally I want to give a
quick shout out to Jason
Bean, Jason thank you so
much for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word,
and for posting a video
about it on your YouTube
channel, I really appreciate
the support man, and I'm so
glad you enjoyed the read.
- [Jason] There it is, Your
One Word, by Evan Carmichael.
- So thank you guys again for
watching, I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe
in yourself and whatever
your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.
- Embrace your quirks,
embrace your weirdness and
from a stuttering point of view
don't treat it as an issue.
Work through it and get the
treatment that you want to get
but don't ever treat it as
an issue and don't see it as
a plight on your life.
The thing that makes you
cool is as you said earlier,
not giving a.
And I'm never going to hide
the fact that I'm a very
competitive person and I
do want this to be biggest
album in the world and I'm
going to make sure it is
the biggest album in the world.
There's going to be no
stone left unturned.
- I love that you have totally
stayed true to yourself
in your songs, with your
style, just with your career
in general.
So if you could, I would
like to know how you would
encourage other young twenty
somethings to stay true
to themselves without letting
other people bring them down.
- No one can be you better than you can.
I know that's quite an obvious
thing but I think people
forget that people try to
model themselves on what other
people are doing, and
everyone has their flaws
and flaws are what make you human.